[Music]
that's not animals this is hungry people
that people are looking just for food
please I don't think I'm opposed eyes
doing something did we can rather die of
quarantine - da Wanga
[Music]
Defiant's / South African President
Cyril Ramaphosa strict lockdown
protesters say his measures are leaving
millions of people struggling to support
themselves like many other Africans
they've been left with a choice hunger
or infection only a tiny fraction of the
continents total population is infected
according to official figures some
24,000 confirmed cases but health
systems are fragile poverty is high and
many more face starvation I'm Ben 4
zulan Africa's got so much more to deal
with than this virus unrest famine even
deadlier diseases and severe measures to
contain covert 19 are leaving so many
people fighting to survive that includes
South Africa's huge migrant population a
nationwide lockdown means those running
businesses need to apply for permits
that are mostly off-limits for
foreigners the corona outbreak is a
battle for survival for this Zimbabwean
family in downtown Johannesburg - food
and then I'm trying to sell this little
piece of spinach so that I can put
something on the table for my family a
five week lockdown brought most
businesses to a grinding halt
including the restaurant where an Kasim
Alok Kumar low eked out a living for the
last nine years
but he needs a permit to sell something
that he doesn't have forcing him to sell
illegally because I'm an illegal
immigrant I cannot manage to get the
permit to sell even this spinach so
that's why I decided to sell outside my
building so that even when the police
become
I easily run inside my building the
country's informal sector provides up to
two and a half million jobs but the
government put strict restrictions in
place during the lockdown and threatens
some with legal action exclusions such
as undocumented migrants and people
without existing trading permits this is
a problem because members of society
were already vulnerable before the
lockdown are the ones who are now paying
the highest price for the lockdown army
and police scoured the streets day and
night to enforce social distancing and
arrest people loitering meaning both
selling and buying in the informal
sector carry a massive risk
I'm fine here from my brother because we
are all immigrants from Zimbabwe we can
it's really tough because there's no
food who are not working we are trying
to support each other we're stuck here
living in this country we cannot go back
Kamala hasn't had a good day
he's only earn 3 euros to feed his
family for each business with the
lockdown extended until the end of April
and food already running short for many
analysts say social unrest is all but
assured well the pandemic may have been
slow to reach Africa but the number of
cases is increasing fast jumping by over
50% last week there are now almost
24,000 confirmed cases across the
continent northern Africa has seen a
significant outbreak with hotspots
forming in Morocco and Egypt South
Africa is worst-affected
with some 3,000 official infections that
high numbers due in part to the
country's aggressive testing regime
that's critical to protecting South
Africans health but is stretching
laboratories to their limits Africa
health expert and entrepreneur and his
dark horde joins us from Cape Town you
helped pioneer Africa's first to HIV
treatment rollout in Botswana you've
advised numerous governments how's the
continent dealing with this outbreak
well as you've just been highlighting
the systemic deficits that exist in the
continent in terms of tackling
gargantuan pandemics such as this as we
you can see treatment is not an option
right if you compare the kind of
resources in infrastructure you have in
for example Europe where they are
struggling where they have about 4,000
beds for 1 billion people that's 4,000
critical care ICU beds per 1 million
people Africa
maybe about five beds per 1 million
people why if you look at certain
countries like South Sudan for example
you have a population of 12 million
people with four ventilators according
to the IRC so we have to get prevention
right and that is why you'll see in most
African countries in particular with the
example of South Africa leading with a
very aggressive lockdown is really the
way to prevent this thing from taking
hold because if it does take hold as it
has in some of northern European
counterparts it would be absolutely
devastating and so as difficult as these
issues are these are structural
challenges that have long existed and I
think Ovid exemplifies why we should
have addressed them earlier but since
covert is here now it's going to be a
delicate balancing act between making
sure we get prevention right while
taking care of the vulnerable
populations
what about preventing the unrest so I
mean that's going to be the main
challenge here we've got millions of
people facing hunger locusts have
destroyed entire crops in regions and
and now these lockdowns well yes exactly
and I think knowing that there's always
a scarce resources to deal with health
there's also scarce resources to deal
with things like food hunger providing
electricity or energy to people and so
when you have scarce resources and you
have such massive wide-scale challenges
the first thing you need is data to
understand where do you have the biggest
deficit so that you can deploy your
scarce resources most effectively and I
think the imperative therefore right now
is for African countries including South
Africa to really be able to quickly
pinpoint the spots where there's going
to be trouble based on poor fundamentals
being in place lack of water lack of
electricity high poverty etc and get in
there to provide the social mitigating
programs that are required so that
people can actually adhere to the
criteria that will ultimately protect us
all we've been talking about data
briefly you've you've launched a mobile
app to stop the spread of covert 19 how
could it ease the situation
it gives you real-time information about
what's evolving so it allows you on
terms of the population side to screen
people geomap whether you found a key
actual case or someone who suspected
also to find at-risk populations people
who are at risk meaning they're not
infected yet but they have diabetes or
hypertension and we know those are
predisposing risk factors and to be able
to therefore asthma protect them from
from getting infected by making sure for
example they self isolate etc but more
importantly has given you a data on
what's going on at the community in real
time so example if people say we don't
have water or food this is a this is a
in essence a direct red-hot telephone
line to say get in there and provide
these things so that people can actually
get here so for example if you don't
have water you can't do the hand-washing
if you do not have electricity
you cannot keep disposable food in your
fridge for long enough you know to to be
able to actually not have to go out
frequently to get it and then if you
don't have work because of the lockdown
you don't have money to afford food or
electricity so if it really is
imperative that it's a holistic approach
it's not just viewed as a clinical issue
so social determinants are as
aggressively dealt with as the clinical
issues as Sacco thank you very much for
joining us my pleasure now to our viewer
questions on the coronavirus our science
editor Derek Williams has the answers
for you who came up with this lockdown
idea although lockdown feels like an
unprecedented step to us at the moment
confinement is actually a tool that's
been used for centuries to contain
epidemics that's because if you lack
access to drugs for treating an
infectious disease or a vaccine to
prevent it limiting how much people
interact with each other is pretty much
the only way to slow its spread many of
the measures that we're seeing today
including things like like closed
borders contact tracing or social
distancing were first attempted in the
late Middle Ages and run
by Italian city-states desperate to
mitigate the effects of the plague waves
of it regularly killed huge numbers of
people there throughout the centuries
since lockdowns have been employed time
and again when infectious deadly
diseases left societies with no other
recourse can we eliminate the virus
completely well this would be the
ultimate goal right but don't expect it
to happen anytime soon we've eradicated
infectious diseases before just think
smallpox we even managed to eradicate
another zoonotic coronavirus SARS after
it broke out in 2002 but there's a key
difference between it and kovat nineteen
people who get Koba 19 can infect others
before they start to show symptoms
themselves so during the incubation
period that wasn't the case with SARS
kovat 19 is much more transmissible and
that characteristic is what's going to
make it very difficult to get on top of
this disease most experts agree at this
point that kovat 19 is likely with us to
stay and will probably turn into an
endemic background pathogen like flu
bugs
which country in Europe has the most
cases of kovat 19 well currently Spain
has more confirmed cases of kovat 19
than any other European country although
more people have died from the disease
in Italy but we should always really
take statistics like this with a grain
of salt because both testing and
record-keeping vary a lot from country
to country we haven't agreed on any
international standards for for who is
to be tested and we don't even agree on
what constitutes a death by coronavirus
because testing capacities are limited
most countries are only testing people
who are presenting at centers that have
clear symptoms in countries where
testing is more widely available people
with piu or or no symptoms might be
tested and that could make a huge
difference in the number of cases that
are detected so it's important to
remember those differences when trying
to compare what's happening in one
country with what's happening in another
[Music]